You're on stage. Hammed. Hamid.
>> Yeah. Do you hear me, guys?
>> Yeah, we hear you. Hamid, how are you?
>> Yes, I'm good. It's very good that we
have this discussion about the Islamic
dilemma.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's one of our favorite
discussions. We think that the Quran at
least in 18 different verses confirms
our scriptures.
>> Yeah. First of all, I just want to thank
Michael because I usually watch
Michael's video
>> on Tik Tok. I love his reputation of
this child marriage thing.
>> Oh, good.
>> I'm glad you I'm glad you're against
child marriage. That is great.
>> You're you're you're okay with us.
You're you're good with us on that
issue.
>> Yeah, because I am originally from
Afghanistan, but I live in Sweden. So,
we have a lot of problem especially in
the rural areas like there are a lot of
child marriages going on. Yeah. So, it
is
>> that is a huge problem.
>> Yeah. You people speak about that. So
this is uh on in the whole Islamic world
at least we have this problem to deal
with it like
>> it's it's a question where where do you
think they get that where do you think
they get that idea from?
>> Yeah.
>> Hold on hold on real quick. Are you a
Muslim sir?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. So so where do you think they get
that from? Where do they get that from?
>> Yes. because we have uh like hadith
which we personally believe that not all
hadith should be treated equally because
they are not all reliable. So any hadith
that that goes against the teachings of
the Quran should be rejected but not
>> so goes against the Quran.
>> Child marriage I personally believe that
it goes against the teachings of the
Quran because at least the Quran is not
super clear.
>> This is going to get into a different
topic Avery but if you want we can
>> yeah we can go down that route or not.
He was he was just given uh IP uh you
know props because he speaks out against
that. But it depends where you want to
go.
>> I we can get back to the Islamic
dilemma. I'm just really happy to hear
from a Muslim who is against child
marriage because we need more of that.
If more Muslims were against child
marriage, it would it would it would not
be a huge problem where girls are
basically being tortured. So I'm all for
finding more Muslims against child
marriage for the safety of these girls.
So, do you think you're right and all
the Islamic countries are wrong about
the Quran?
>> No, I because it is not just me like
there are a lot of Muslims also. We are
in minority that are against the
teachings of
>> Okay. So, the Okay. The minority in the
Islamic world is against child marriage.
Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And the majority is for child
marriage. Correct.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because
>> So, who's more correct? The majority or
the minority about the religion? Because
as Michael usually say that we cannot
determine the truth by the majority.
>> Yeah. But that's not what Muhammad said.
Muhammad said that his nation cannot go
astray on a point. So if the majority
agree on something, I know that
logically this is a fallacy. But
Muhammad said that if the majority agree
on something, they have a consensus and
therefore it's good.
>> Yeah. But since tonight discussion is
about the Islamic
stuff for you to think that's okay.
>> Yeah. Some stuff for you to think about
as to where the problem is.
>> 654.
>> Yeah. 65.
>> So, in the Quran, it says that it
confirms our scriptures at least in 18
different verses. So, do you accept that
the Quran confirms our scriptures that
we have today?
>> Yes. I I I personally believe because I
read the Quran a lot, different
translations. And to be honest with you,
there is no at least a verse which is
super clear that tells us that the Jews
and Christian scriptures is corrupt that
there is no such vers in the entire
>> Thank you for saying that.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. As you got
to call out good stuff when I see it.
Thank you for saying that.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Sorry. Go on. You want to say
something?
>> Honest. Because at least
as a believer, we should be honest. Even
the Quran says when we speak, be jazzed.
So we don't have a single verse and I
agree completely with David with that
once challenged like gave us one clear
verse which says so we don't have such a
verse like
>> that's really great to hear. So my issue
would be with the Quran in general that
because of these 18 verses they use the
Masonic word in Arabic to confirm the
scriptures we have. I also notice in the
Quran that there are doctrines, there
are beliefs, theological statements that
fundamentally contradict that scripture
that I have today as a Christian. And
for that reason, it seems to be as if
the Quran is doing two things. On the
one hand, the Quran is confirming my
scriptures in those 18 verses. But on my
on the other hand, the Quran seems to be
contradicting that very scripture that
it claims to affirm. And so we're kind
of in this dilemma because on the one
hand the Quran is confirming our
scriptures and if we accept that we
acknowledge theological differences so
the Quran is in fault. But on the other
hand if the Quran is not actually
confirming our scriptures and the QR is
an error because it makes it very clear
over and over again that's what it's
trying to do but it seems to fail to do
so. So how would you how would you
resolve that then as a Muslim?
>> Yes. I I think like this because for
example if we read chapter 5 chapter 5
verse 47 and then chapter 5 verse 68
which enjoin the Jews and Christian to
stand on their scripture and whatever
has been revealed to them from their
lord. So I personally think like this
because I I don't know so much about the
Bible. I'm not a scholar of the Bible.
If the Bible teaches that Jesus is God,
if that is what the what the Bible
teaches, that means that there is some
problem with the Quran. But if the Bible
does not teach that Jesus is God, so
that means that even if the Quran
confirms the Christians and Jewish
scripture, so it it doesn't make the
Quran to be false. So here my issue
because not all Christian agree what the
Bible teaches. Okay, I I understand that
because obviously we we have some
doctrines that we have that are holistic
like we find them all over scripture and
therefore when we say that we believe in
the trinity when we say that Jesus is
God we have many different verses to go
into and that can be quite time
consuming to go through all of them
because there's quite a lot. So what I
think might help is if we just look at
some very plain things in the gospels
for example that are very very clear
like you know they're not um
theologically
uh what's the word um they don't have
like a high christologology necessarily
but rather they're just statements of
fact. So, one could be that the
crucifixion occurred, right? That could
be one. I mean, you say you haven't like
you're not a scholar of the Bible. Fine.
But if we if we go Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John, each of these books say that
Jesus was crucified without exception.
In fact, it's the it's one of the
pinnacle highlights. It's one of the the
very events that, you know, the authors
are getting to, which is his crucifixion
and then ultimately his resurrection and
ascension. These are big things.
>> Yeah. Another one for example just just
so I'll finish that point the Quran in
surah surah 4 surah and ayah 157 seems
to be denying that and that's a
traditional Sunni Shia interpretation
but when we look those seem to be
contradicting and I don't really think
you can reconcile that from your
position I think you would have to
abandon that position otherwise you
would have to see that the Quran is
contradicting itself
>> yeah but to be honest here is like even
do it when we made a video about this
surah 147. That is an interpretation
because the Quran is not super clear
about whether Jesus was crucified or
not. It just says that it was appeared
to them.
>> That's a really good point. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
Many for example when God
>> when when God when when in the Quran we
read that those who are killed in the
way of God they are not dead. So we can
interpret that verse that even if from
the perspective of those Jews who claim
that they killed Jesus but in reality
Jesus is not dead. So there is one
interpretation and there are many other
interpretation.
>> So just because the majority of Sunnis
hold a view that Jesus didn't c crucify
that doesn't mean that the Quran says
that
>> right that's a really good point like
you can totally have that
interpretation. I think that's I think
that's great. That's obviously out of
line with the majority uh orthodox
opinion, but I I think that's uh
Quranically valid. I think you can make
arguments for that as David has pointed
out.
>> There are other things though that are
also going to come because I I gave one
example, but there's an entire list of
these. Another one could be that Jesus
refers to God as his heavenly father.
Mhm.
>> The Quran in many places like surah ala
ay 18 and elsewhere explicitly denies
that Allah has in any sense a child or
he is in any sense a father. It denies
this explicitly. So on the one hand
Jesus says that actually God is a father
in one way and then the Quran says there
is no way in which Allah is a father.
Yes, Chris, I agree with you because the
problem that that I have even as a
Muslim with some verses of the Quran
that it talks when it talks about the
Christian faith, it talks in a way that
it is not what the Christians believe.
For example, when the Quran talks about
the trinity like it says those who
people who say those who say that uh God
is the third of three, so they do
blasphe. They do blasphem who say that
God is the third of three or when it's
when it says about the deity of Jesus
that they do blasphem who say that God
is Jesus. No Christians that I in Sweden
I go to churches no Christian ever say
that God is Jesus. That is not totally
correct because we say that Jesus is
God. When no Christian say that God is
the third of three. So when the Quran
>> talks about the Christian faith
sometimes I have really difficulty to
understand because the trinitarian
Christian that we have today doesn't
speak like that which it is is spoken in
the Quran like I haven't seen that
Michael said that God is the third of
three. What does that mean the third of
three? That is a really good point and
remember the Quran elsewhere says that
um that Jesus is asked actually did you
tell people to take him Jesus Allah and
his mother as gods besides Allah? Now no
Christian has ever believed that there
there's there's massive problems with
that statement. We don't think that God
is three three separate gods. We don't
believe that at all. That would put you
out of uh Christianity immediately. And
we also don't think that there's Jesus
Allah and his mother Mary. Like no
Christian believes that. And you know,
you go to a Roman Catholic and you
explain that to them, they will call you
out and say, "No, if you believe that,
you're not part of the Roman Catholic
Church at all." And that's historic. We
can show that historically. Uh it's not
even in question. So the question I
guess then is if the Quran seems to talk
this way about theological statements
that don't seem to align with
Christians, what is the best explanation
for why the Quran is doing that?
Now to me it looks as if the Quran
author although they knew a lot about
what's uh what the Christians and Jews
say is in their scripture what they
believe because obviously the Quran
author you know he talks about Moses,
Abraham, Joseph, Jacob, you know he
talks about all these prophets gives all
these stories but at the same time
although he's aware of all this he
doesn't quite know what's actually
written down. He doesn't have access to
what's written. He can't look at the
Injeal or the Torah in the seventh
century that's present with these
groups, these Jews and these Christians
to verify that what he's saying is
actually true or not. He's in effect
using the best of his knowledge that
he's heard probably orally to try and
fill these gaps in. And that's why in
the Quran we see sometimes the Quran
author just doesn't quite get it right.
Now that to me is a sign of a human
author. What do you think?
>> Yes. I I really like I myself have
really struggled with this because the
trinitarian Christian that I interact
with so I know what they believe exactly
like at least about God being triune and
I also watched Michael's video and I
know what Christian believes. So that's
why we don't have a clear statement in
the Quran to describe these things. For
example, if the Quran said like this
that they do blasphe who say that God is
one being and three persons, then we
could say okay now here it's talking
about the trinity but the Quran doesn't
speak like that. The Quran say that God
is the third of three. So here there is
one interpretation there is one guy I
don't remember his name he is not a
Muslim but he says like this that the
Quran does speak about the trinity here
but it deliberately speak in a in a in a
misunderstanding way to give a message
to people that the concept of the
trinity is something that can be
misunderstood. So that can be like a
valid point as an interpretation but to
be honest the plain text of the Quran
doesn't tell us what the Christian
believe exactly about these things. So
my point my point is when it comes to
the Islamic dilemma I agree that I
personally believe when the Quran says
in 547 that let the people of the gospel
it use the singular word gospel because
in Christianity we use the word gospel
for example for the four gospels but
also we use the word gospel for the
whole message of Christianity like Jesus
when we say the message of Jesus is the
gospel. So it can be like that when the
Quran says people let people of the
gospel judge is like the Christian who
believe in the message of Jesus should
judge. So my point is that if we somehow
show or confirm that the Bible really
teaches that God is triune so that will
be a problem for the Quran. But if we
don't establish that that the Bible is
doesn't teach, if the Bible doesn't
teach that God is a trinity, then even
if the Quran confirms the Jewish and and
Christian scripture, so it still doesn't
show that the Quran is false.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I just want to I just want
to point out because uh me and IP have
to cut out here pretty soon. What uh
what what's your what's your name again?
>> Hamid.
>> Hamid. Yeah. So what Hamida is saying is
basically what I've been saying for a
while that I would believe what what
what would I do and what would I believe
if for some reason I came to be
convinced that the Quran is from God.
It's actually revealed scripture. And I
just I've said I couldn't go the route
of the da guys and just pretend that the
Quran doesn't affirm the previous
scriptures. It makes no sense. There's
two it's if it was one verse you could
reinterpret it. If it's dozens and
dozens of verses, you can't just say,
"Oh, Allah means something completely
different from what he says in all these
places." I said, "If I were to believe
that the Quran is from God, I would also
have to recognize that it's affirming
these previous scriptures, which seem to
be seem to be saying some different
things." And so, what would I do in that
situation? I'd do what he was just
doing. I would say okay uh the Quran
most Muslims interpret it as denying the
crucifixion but the the the previous
scriptures are completely clear that
Jesus died by crucifixion and therefore
I need to I need to look again at what
the what the Quran is saying here and in
that case I'd have to say okay well 355
sounds like it's saying something else
and there there have been other Muslims
who interpreted this differently so you
know what I'm going to interpret 4 157
in a way that doesn't conflict with the
Christian belief that Jesus died by
crucifixion. So in other words, if you
believe that if you actually believe
what the Quran is saying, the Quran is
the word of God, the scriptures in the
possession of the Jews and Christians
are the word of God, then your effort
would have to be in harmonizing them,
harmonizing them and interpreting them
in a way where they're not contradicting
each other. And so yes, you have to go
kind of doctrine by doctrine and try to
reconcile all of them. Now the issue is,
can that be done? Can that actually be
done on every issue? But that's what I
would have to do. That's what I would
have to do if I believed that the Quran
is the word of God. Knowing what the
Quran says about the previous
scriptures, this is what I would have to
do. So, um, so I I agree with you. I
agree with his approach. I actually
respect this approach way more than I
respect the Dawa guys just, oh, no,
that's not what the Quran says. And
then, and then throwing everything Allah
said under the bus. Uh, so yeah, quite
quite refreshing. Quite refreshing. And
I don't I don't believe the Quran is the
word of God. But if I did, I would have
to go in the direction that Hamid here
is going.
>> And if if if if I can, you said you
don't know the Bible. Could I just show
you a verse where Jesus is called God?
>> Yes, please, Michael. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Let's just let's let me just put
my screen up because I'll just go to
John 1:1 because Hey, everyone put my
screen up there. John 1:1. In the
beginning was the word and the word was
with God and the word was God. He was
with God in the beginning. Jesus is
called the word throughout this chapter.
So right here, John opens the his gospel
by telling us Jesus is God. And even if
you go down here to verse 18, no one has
ever seen God. God the only son who is
at the father's side. He has made him
known. There we see again Jesus is
confirmed because here we see the son is
also confirmed to be God. So right then
and there we have a problem with the
Quran because the gospels are clearly
teaching Jesus is God especially in John
where it's very explicit. So this is a
verse we bring up a lot. If that's the
case it does seem like there's a
contradiction with the Quran.
>> My friend just just to say I think you
should get yourself maybe the Gospel of
John and start reading it. start reading
what IP is showing on the screen now and
and seriously think is the Quran getting
this right or is the Quran misunderstood
does the Quran author not really know
all things perhaps the author of the
Quran is actually human and perhaps
Muhammad although he was trying his best
couldn't quite articulate what was
written in our scriptures and um and I
also think that reading this would be
very eye opening for you and I very much
encourage you to do so solemnly and in
your own time and to keep in mind the
desire to follow the prophets that God
has sent over time through through many
different nations, many uh many
different prophets all with the same
message. And I think that Christ is the
fulfillment of the Old Testament and
what was prophesized to the children of
Israel. And I think that's ultimately
what what you should keep in mind when
you read this.
>> Amen. Exactly. And if if uh if he's
still listening cuz he he pointed out
the verse in the Quran that said Allah
is the third of three. Um Allah also
misunderstands the trinity in another
verse surah 5:72. Because if you go by
Allah is the third of three they assume
Allah is the father. But then in surah
5:72 it says m is Allah. They think
>> I I got to get going. But please keep
watching my videos and you can re send
me a message on TikTok if you want to
talk cuz I think that's where you said
you were watching them. So, just if you
want to talk more about this, just send
me a message on TikTok and I'll look for
it. But I gota I do got to take off
because I have evening prayer I have to
get to every Friday. So, thanks for
having me, guys.
>> I have to head out too.
>> I have to head out too. Got another live
stream. Way better one. Way better one
than that. And uh here
>> No, it's actually Yeah, we're going over
Ali had I think Dean responds or
something on there. Muhammad and Isaiah
42. So, we're going to go and take a
look at that. Yep. Yep. Yep. So, we're
going to go check that out. All right,
we'll catch y'all next time. And
GodLogic, I'm guessing uh I'll be
debating over on your channel next week.
So, I I guess so. We'll we'll we'll see,
man. It sure
>> be interesting. It be interesting. All
right.
>> God bless. God bless. God bless you
guys. God bless you.